رجل امريكي غادر بلاده في طفولته ثم عاد
اليها في شبابه حيث عمل بتجاره الجلود
هكذا بدا المشهد من منظور الامريكيين قبل
ان يدركوا ان هذا الامريكي هو صاحب
التوقيع الذي حملته اخطر رسائل التجسس
التي بلغت ايديا النازيين انذاك كورت
لودفيج فما قصته
ولد كورد فريد في مدينه فريموند في ولايه
اوهايو عام
1903 وانتقل الى المانيا مع والديه عندما
كان عمره ست سنوات
فترعرع وتزوج هناك قبل ان تجنده الحكومه
الاشتراكيه الوطنيه كجاسوس لديها قام
لودفيج بمهامه تجسسيه عديده لصالح
النازيين قبل ان يتم القبض عليه من قبل
الشرطه النمساويه وهو يلتقط صورا على
حدودها مع المانيا في فبراير من العام
ولكنه نجامع استيلاء النازيين على النمسا
في الشهر التالي فعاد الى المانيا وبقي
فيها حتى مارس من العام
1940 عندما امر بالعوده الى الولايات
المتحده عند وصوله الى الولايات المتحده
انتحل لودفيج شخصيه تاجر جلود وزاره
تقريبا كل معسكر للجيش المباراه الجويه في
الساحل الشرقي كما زار العديد من الارصفه
والموانئ وقام بتشكيل حلقه تجسسيه من سته
شباب قليلي الخبره باستثناء المستشار
الفني للمجموعه هو البورشارد الضابط
المتقاعد من الجيش الالماني اضافه الى
امراتين اهداءهما سكرتيره مساعده له
جمع لودفيج مع فريقه من المعلومات بخصوص
حجم ومعدات وموقع الجيش والبحريه
الامريكيه وقواعد القوات الجويه كما حصلوا
على تفاصيل مهمه حول انتاج الاسلحه
وتحركات القوافل كخطه الامريكان للدفاع عن
بيرل هاربر ومصانع الطائرات في منطقه لونج
ايلاند حيث تم ارسالها بطرق موثوقه الى
عناوين بريديه في المانيا وفي دول اخرى
كاسبانيا والبرتغال والارجنتين والمانيا
كانت الرسائل تبدو كانها ذات طابع شخصي
الى ان تصل الى الشخص المتلقي في المانيا
ليكشف عن الرساله الاصليه التي كتبت
باستخدام حبر سري وحملت جميعها توقيع وهو
احد الاسماء الرمزيه التي استخدمها لودفيج
وهو الاسم الذي نسب لشبكته لاحقا في اغسطس
من العام 1941
القبض على من قبل مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه بتهمه التامر لخرق قوانين
التجسس فحكم عليه وعلى بورشارد بالسجن
عشرين عاما لكل منهما ثم نقل بعدها الى
سجن في جزيره الكاتراز حتى عام
1953 حيث تم اطلاق سراحه وترحيله من
الولايات المتحده ولكن اثره اختفى بعدها
ولم يعرف حتى تاريخ وفاته رغم ان فتره
عمله التجسسيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كانت قصيره الا ان المعلومات
التي قدمها للنازيين كانت بمثابه ثروه
كبيره وصلت مباشره الى كبار قاده هتلر
فكان احد اهم رجالات الرايخ الثالث خلال
الحرب العالميه الثانيه